this one I think is the most interesting
one because one of the things that I
sense that the Trump camp and the Tucker
types are hitting DeSantis on more is
the Ukraine stance where he doesn't seem
to be for nation building or big Wars
but he hasn't been anti-war enough so
here is his position on Ukraine the war
in general and Putin specifically
well we stop putting
Putin's gin for a leader who's got a
look at the world and very clear-eyed
glasses you know that it's not all
peaches and cream out there and you have
to make a judgment about what's in
America's national interest and so
that's the position that I believe and I
also believe that
I wish the D.C Elites cared as much
about our border as they do about the
ukraine-russia Border because there's
people pouring into this country we have
people dying from fencing all overdose
the cartels are running the show and
what I've said is this is something on
day one declare a National Emergency
mobilize all resources including the
military Stop The Invasion yes build the
wall but most importantly authorize the
border patrol authorize our military to
deal with the cartels if they're
breaking into our country bringing
product if I'm in charge that's going to
be the last thing they do because
they're going to end up stone cold dead
do you agree with the guy's policies and
do you think he can do it I think
there's every reason to believe that on
day one he would mobilize the military
and that we would be defending the
border and it was interesting because
you know when we showed you that answer
earlier from Tim Scott and Tim Scott
basically when Tucker asked him about
Mexico and Ukraine he sort of was just
kind of me it didn't he didn't do much
it was just lukewarm well we can do both
we can sort of do something about Mexico
and Fentanyl and we can still help
Ukraine and DeSantis was like we are
going to deal with the border 100 that
is going to solve the Mexico problem he
then later on went to say he didn't want
this endless war and we've got to put
pressure on Putin Etc et cetera so we'll
find out more about that I do see that
as if you're if you're like the most
isolationist libertarian type which by
the way is just a sliver of of the
voting electorate most people aren't but
I could see that being a concern with
DeSantis and I think we'll find out more
about that as time goes on foreign